to our daily homeroom live stream i'm
excited about our conversation today
with
khan academy's head of engineering vp of
engineering marta casarchin
uh but before we get into that i will
give my standard announcement
uh a reminder to everyone that khan
academy is a not-for-profit that we only
exist
uh because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself a special
thanks to several corporations that
stepped up a couple of months ago
when they found out that we were running
at a deficit even before kovid
and then with all of the things we've
been trying to do in response to
covid our deficit has only increased
special thanks to bank for america
google.org at t
fastly and novartis and many other
foundations and individual donors of all
levels who make this possible i will say
that we still are running at a deficit
and digging into reserves so
if at any scale if you're in a position
to help please
think about making a donation so with
that
i am excited to introduce marta who is
our
cto and vp of engineering so so
marta thanks for joining in and i'll
remind everyone who's watching on
facebook or youtube
please put questions you have for myself
or marta on the message boards
below we have team members who are going
to be surfacing questions
and they can really be a questions about
anything and everything but we're going
to be talking a lot about
just marta's journey to how she got to
khan academy so it could be about career
advice especially if you're trying to
think about going into a technical field
or engineering
but it literally could be about anything
it could be life advice it could be
how we do engineering it kind of really
any any topic is within bounds
uh so so martha maybe a good place to
start
you're the cto vp of engineering what do
what what do those titles mean what do
you do here at khan academy what do they
mean generally in most organizations
yeah i mean generally most organizations
and at khan academy it's leading the
engineering team
which is the team that build our product
our khan academy
website and provides the learning
experiences
uh that encapsulate the content that we
have
available for our users and helps them
helps them on their learning journey and
all of the things that you often talk
about
uh on daily homeroom so we build that
and so we have to choose the technology
that's appropriate
for us to not only build an appropriate
learning experience but build it in a
way
that provides reasonable performance and
stability
and reliability because that's our
promise that's our service to the
organization
is that we will um we will do the pla we
will
take care of the platform we basically
steward the platform and make the
choices that will
get our product out there yeah and you
know explain to folk you know
i think a lot of people have a
perception that you know it is true khan
academy was started by
me in a walk-in closet actually was this
walk-in closet that i'm in now so it's
still
that part is still has held true there
is a salad a walk-in closet someplace
that's a very nice one as you can tell
has a bookshelf and has some natural
lighting
uh but you know people don't realize
that we're
over 200 person organization we have an
over 80 person engineering team
and so people think well you know i know
khan academy has videos
uh you have some exercises
this is this is a major organization
what
what are what what is requiring us to
have such a
not only a large team but a deep team we
have some of the world's experts in a
lot of the areas
of technology and infrastructure what
what what is the focus of that
engineering team that you lead
yeah that's a great question sal for us
to talk about because
i'll share a story when i um shared with
folks that i was coming to khan academy
and they said well what kind of
engineering
do you need a khan academy because so
many people think oh well
there are some videos right on youtube
that you can go watch
and so i hope i was helpful in in kind
of getting the word out there to come to
our site and our product
and to uh to enjoy uh not only the
videos but the articles
and the exercises in particular and the
mastery mechanics and all of the things
that we provide for
for learners and for teachers and for
parents um
so we have yes over 80 engineers and we
have
a really really spectacular engineering
team we are
so fortunate to have incredibly
incredibly skilled engineers that work
here have come
because of the mission that that you
found at sal
to provide a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and folks come here
who are dedicated to it and who
do really spectacular work uh on the
product
so we are building like i said learning
experiences
we're building teaching experiences and
the engineers are building the site
um so yeah yeah there's a lot of us
people they're very good and and and
what you know just to
doubly underline or triple underline
what you're saying i don't think people
realize that you know when a site
when khan academy had a few thousand
people using it every month
yeah maybe it could operate uh you know
on on
a shoestring and i would say still
operating on a shoestring relative to
its scale obviously it's the budget of a
large high school and reaches over 100
million students every year
but uh to to your points you know we
have to keep it up and running
24 7. we have to make sure it's
performant you know just the data
that we're storing and once again we
only store data in service to students
to make the learning experience better
or to understand efficacy
that by itself is gargantuan we have
uh you know millions of dollars in
server costs that we have to keep
running as efficiently as possible
to your point our product is more
nuanced and complicated than i think
most people realize we have official sat
practice we have
subjects and grades from pre-k all the
way through college
we have multiple modalities we have
teacher aspects tools to it we're
keeping track of everything
we have students things and so you can
imagine just even keeping track of
and and and the game mechanics and the
state for 100 million
plus people it's it's no is no joke and
and we're just kind of glazing glazing
the surface
so before we we get into there's
actually a lot of good questions are
coming in on facebook and youtube
before we get into it marta you know
just share a little bit of your journey
of how you
got to khan academy you know and start
as far back as as you like i think
that's
that's what's unique about homeroom i
think people are intrigued in knowing
folks paths in life okay
well we'll go we'll go far back uh
so i grew up in chicago my parents were
immigrants i'm
a first generation um american and
i uh i think i've shared in two truths
and a lie so you know this sal that
um one of the things i always kind of
use is the fact that i didn't learn to
speak english
until i went to school
and so that was my my very early journey
i um coming to khan academy is something
that i've often said is sort of a coming
full circle
because i started off loving math and
studying math
and i have a couple of degrees
in math and
as as a female in particular my age
going through and being a math major and
going to graduate school the questions
that i always got well why aren't you in
math ed
because you know you should be a teacher
and i
was very adamant adamant about the fact
that i didn't want to be a teacher
i wanted to um just study math
and it wasn't until grad school i was a
ta
that i realized that i fell in love with
teaching
and i think a big insight for me there
which i know you experience
all the time sell um given the content
that you do is just
because i was learning so much every
time i had to just
i really had to talk about the same
concept even in classes and they'd
repeat
obviously for a grad student as a ta i'd
learned something new right there's
something else i'd discover some
physical phenomenon that i could relate
it to
so anyway i did that for a while i was
always in applied mathematics and i
got really interested in coding because
i had to do coding to do my work
and i eventually studied computer
science as well
and uh came out to silicon valley for a
bit
to try it out uh with hp and i ended up
spending a long time almost 15 years at
hp
and have worked in the software business
i came originally doing cad algorithms
still leveraging my math background a
lot uh and then moved to distributed
systems and really worked long time
long term and distributed systems
research at hp labs and
uh and working on some of the first
products for broadband
uh distributed systems and the on the uh
and the internet obviously the advent of
the internet
which um is something that i experienced
and uh anyway coming to khan academy
finally in my software development
journey and
and leading engineering teams has been
kind of like a dream come true because
it's sort of full circle it's
i've was a big fan of khan academy for a
long time and the fact that i could join
and help with the engineering experience
leadership that i've had
and contribute to the mission that way
is pretty special
to me and that leads to a question from
youtube az
asks why did you choose to work with
khan academy and i'll add to that
question because one of the questions i
got
in the early days of khan academy when i
wanted to set it up and i did set it up
as a not-for-profit
is i got a lot of skepticism that you
will not be able to attract
top technical talent especially in the
bay area
we're literally a few miles down the
road from google from facebook from
apple uh you know we pay well but we
can't give stock because we don't have
any
everyone watching has as much stock as
you and i have in khan academy
so what was you know you are someone uh
that
could be the cto at nearly any company
in the valley and
you know and i don't want to i don't
want to make you tempted but you could
make me
making millions of dollars every year um
why i'll just you know that's just
adding to to the question from az on
youtube why khan academy
my khan academy it's a great question uh
well first of all i was a khan academy
fan for a long time
uh and sal i know when i think
interviewed with you i shared my stories
about like that i said boy when i
discovered sal's
style site it was basically people would
always ask me to explain like math
things to them and i said you know
there's this guy online that does so
much better job than i
ever did you really should just kind of
look at these
and so anyway i was a big fan and so i
feel very privileged to come to
contribute to the mission
now i uh had some trepidation about
building an
engineering team especially when i came
we've scaled very quickly in the three
years that i've been here
the team was less than half the size
that it is today
and uh our growth has been major i
mean just just this spring
uh because of the covet 19 situation of
course in schools closing
our usage grew as you've talked about uh
quite a bit 250
very quickly uh which as an aside
is something i'm very very proud of our
team uh about the fact that we were able
to sustain that kind of growth
and not cause hiccups for our learners
when they desperately needed us
and when we had all of those amazing
schedules and materials
to serve up for families and students
who were just all of a sudden
at home and everybody was scrambling to
adjust
but anyway i did have some trepidation
about hiring
uh at a nonprofit and i
can say that this is the strongest team
that i have ever had
anywhere uh not making this up
this is absolutely the truth we have
amazing folks here who came for the
mission who come for the mission
every day and are also spectacularly
talented and focused
on this mission and the lever that we
have
in today's world with all of the events
that are going on today
to be able to work somewhere right now
and i'm
and we're all working very hard long
hours we can talk about some of our
projects
i don't know that i could do it if i
wasn't working on this mission
to be honest and uh really thinking
about the impact that we have
every single day on so many people uh
you know as you know when we started
exploding i i was working very long days
and i said to a bunch of my friends um
you know i just
i couldn't do this anymore if i was like
in the corporate world
but at khan academy it's uh
the reward is pretty major yeah
yeah no no you know i think you're an
example of it and everyone on the
engineering team everyone on the team
broadly at khan academy
i remember when i was working as an
analyst at a hedge fund which is a very
i guess you could say money driven
industry by definition that's all it's
driven by really
i remember reading a research study uh
that said that actually the top
performers in a field
they aren't motivated by money uh they
do need enough money to live and support
their family and buy a house and go on
vacations and send their kids to college
and that type of thing
but beyond that kind of sufficient level
uh they care much more about
impact uh challenging work
and being able to work with other
aligned people and you know the fact
that
folks like yourself and the entire team
at khan academy have joined i think is
is evidence i was skeptical about when i
read that paper when i was
i was very coin operated back then but i
think it's absolutely true
um so from youtube
lorena says marta what are your passions
your true passions at work and out of it
my true passions at work my my true
passions
at work are uh first of all it is my
team
so leading leading the team which is
more than just the technical work that
we have
but really the work that we do on
creating a cohesive
organization we updated our engineering
principles about a year ago
and the team worked on them and we're
very proud of those two
because it says a lot about the kind of
people that we are
and the way that we want to treat each
other as an org
at the organization at work always and
the way that we want to focus on the
quality of what we deliver
to our users is a very impact i'm so i'm
very passionate about that
building the team and and having a
strong team of folks who are happy and i
really miss being in the office uh
during shelter and place really really
miss being in the office because i'm
somebody
who long ago learned back at hp about
management by wandering around and i'm a
wanderer around her and loved to stop
and chat with everybody and
and i do and that's an important part of
my day so i'm very passionate about that
and the other thing i'm very very
passionate about is delivering for our
users
so i i can be very driven by
the results execution which for us means
uh quickly and with high quality
delivering new learning experiences new
teaching experiences and things for
parents
a cell talk you talked about the test
prep so many experiences that are
that we know are are are a big lover in
today's world
and what just to you know ask lorena's
question again because and you know
marta isn't just giving a diplomatic
answer just knowing her and having the
i love it you know you said everything
about work and obviously that sounds
good to me but
obviously uh you know we pride ourselves
on on making sure people here have full
full lives and i i mean i also have
trouble sometimes
extracting myself from work because it's
a passion but you know what what
what what other things what other things
yes and my family will be very
disappointed if they ever want to
know that i started with the work
response but obviously my family is
important to me
uh my husband and uh my daughter i have
a daughter
that i'm very proud of is uh clerking on
the u.s
court of appeals in washington dc right
now and
is a big part of my life and teaches me
a lot about
uh the culture of today uh uh
and the culture of her age and which is
very helpful for me
in terms of my um organizational
knowledge
uh and my husband uh who's a biochemist
we are all kind of systems
people we think a lot of abstract kind
of system
stuff and you know do nerdy things my
husband and i are doing a lot of jigsaw
puzzles
playing cribbage you know stuff like
that
uh up until a few years ago i was very
passionate i have to say this because
all of my friends if they ever see this
will say what about beach volleyball
because i played beach volleyball for
many many years and that was my
my biggest passion outside of work uh
but
my knees aren't uh really loving
anymore so not so much
no that's that's a little known fact
about khan academy that we could
probably field a pretty mean
beach volleyball or volleyball team
between you and then ginny
lee who's our president and ceo y'all
would be the the core of the team i
suspect
there's a few others that could
contribute as a as
as well so there's a couple questions
here that i think are pretty interesting
and maybe related
um so prasad tota asks
from youtube what is the hardest part
about being at khan academy i haven't
gotten that question before but it's an
interesting one
and then there's another he also asked a
simpler question how does the pandemic
affect khan academy and that could be
internally or externally i'd love i'd
love your your take on
what's hard about this job and uh how
have it how has it changed with the
pandemic
yeah that's a really interesting
question uh what's hard about this job
um i
i don't want to sound like a pollyanna
but honestly this is like the funnest
job i've ever had so i
i'm just gonna say that i i i love what
i do
i love the people that i work with and i
believe
every day i'm so it's so reinforced for
me about the impact that we're having
um on the world so it's really hard to
say what's hard what's hard is that
there's a lot to do
um what's hard is that we are at a stage
of our growth
where um we are working on a project
that we have code named goliath
uh which we have posted about in our
blogs
and it's called goliath because we are
uh basically moving our back-end server
monolith
of about 800 000 lines of code from
python 2
to a services
based architecture written in go
so it's big and it's going in to go so
goliath
is hard we have a fantastic
team who's doing a great job on it but
it is
a hard a hard thing to do uh as
as one of my leaders on the team that
manages the platform says
uh it's like we're still flying the
plane
and it's kind of all in pieces but we're
still keeping everybody
all the passengers on the plane and
flying the plane
um or i say it's kind of like um
switching out the
foundation in from under your house the
entire foundation while
you're living in the house
and using all the functions so that's
while there's a party in the house and a
pandemic by the way so everybody's
in the house all the time
no that's right and how is that i mean
no exactly i mean
and i you know just to add to that i i
think one of the things
just that i found difficult sometimes
about this job is
almost any other job when you're kind of
really worked up about something or
you want something to be done right you
can kind of go home it's like well it
doesn't really matter
you know if i lose this argument or you
know
it'll you know the company will sell
databases or whatever
you know i used to work at oracle a
great company but that's how i felt
about it sometimes and that would make
me
but at khan academy whenever i feel like
well what's the big deal oh the big deal
is
tens of millions of people might not be
able to learn and so
then you lose that's right and what how
how has the pandemic affected
you know you and how we've been able to
work and you know and
and the things we're working on from
your point of view
yeah that's a that's a great question
too i alluded to part of the answer
earlier when i talked about missing
being in the office
because we're sheltering in place in
santa clara county and we're all working
from home
uh and so that has been hard for me
because i am a wanderer rounder
and uh people person and even though we
have a large
uh remote uh remote set of workers uh
in and engineers in particular and so
we're very good
at remote working actually at khan
academy uh
it's hard for me because it's nice to
see at least part of my team
every day uh and and other folks and
other functions at khan academy every
day so that's hard
some things have been easier some things
have been easier so instead of
in the morning instead of having to rush
and get in the shower and get dressed
and then spend 35 or 40 minutes in the
car
driving to the office i can now enjoy
my morning meditation sitting and
kind of be a lot more uh a lot more
focused
and attuned when i sit down at my desk
so
um for me personally i'm very fortunate
because i'm continuing to work and
we are able to get our um groceries
and yep so i we've been very fortunate
and i'm very cognizant of that so a lot
of what my family has been doing during
the pandemic
is in fact trying to look out for where
we can have a positive
impact even outside of khan academy but
where we can
contribute and volunteer and and help
folks because the pandemic's much harder
for a lot of people than it is
for us yeah and you mentioned you do you
you do you i i've talked about
meditation a lot
and probably more than people want me to
want to hear about it from but i'm
curious
you do meditate and what what got you
started with that and what what do you
feel
it does for you yeah uh well what got me
started for it was a tough time that i
went through with
a health uh situation and a really tough
anxiety time
and so it really was more instrumental
at the time like this is a tool that can
help me because
this is so incredibly difficult to go
through uh and then it's really been
kind of a key part of something that
i've
done a lot of personal growth through
frankly and uh
yes i meditate in the morning during
shelter and place i'll give a plug to
the insight meditation center in redwood
city and
i've been sitting with gil as i say uh
every morning and that's my my morning
meditation and
i was saying to my husband rob earlier
today
my little story about meditation as i
was getting all frazzled
and kind of grumped at him and said you
know i'm just trying to grab this
because i have to go sit
so i feel you know live at seven o'clock
i can't i've got to be there
and uh so it was a moment of growth for
me when i realized okay i've already had
my
my teaching sort of for this morning and
that
i was you know having all that anxiety
about sitting to get my teaching
if i just paused i got i already had my
teaching there so
that's my little vignette for this
morning session
no that's great i've been i've been
dreaming maybe we could still do it in
covet
creating like a meditation club in the
organization we can we can
be two of the the starting together yeah
that'd be nice
that'd be nice so actually there's a
question for me about you
this is interesting so from youtube such
and sile says sal
why do you find marta to be an asset
so that's a great question this is
well you know such a great great
question i you know let me just put it
step take a step back i think you know a
lot of times when you imagine actually
my brain works we've taken like these
personality tests and i'm oftentimes
skeptical of personality tests
uh because you know we can be different
in different cases or uh but you know in
this case i think the personality test
was quite accurate
uh where it said that you know it mapped
them to colors is the one we used but it
essentially i'm red and blue and that
personality test red
means someone who just likes to like get
stuff done
like yesterday as fast as possible and
then blue is someone who likes to think
you know very big picture maybe out of
the box and think about what could the
world be like and dream about a little
bit
and in a lot of ways those are somewhat
stereotypical
traits for uh people who are
entrepreneurial uh you know they think
of these big ideas and they say okay
and i need to try to build it or
prototype it or work on it tomorrow
and that was great in the early days of
khan academy you know the first four or
five years it was literally just me
in this walk-in closet having big big
ideas
but then also saying let me start
hacking this thing together let me code
it together you know i didn't have a
background in computer science
but as you grow an organization you know
one of the things to really appreciate
is where are your
strengths and where do you get energy
and what are your weaknesses
and where do you not get energy and
there could be weaknesses that you just
don't have the skills you don't have the
experience
and so as khan academy has grown i have
gained
ever increasing appreciation for
bringing in people
who have the depth and the experience to
know how to lead teams
scale teams have technical depth that i
didn't have
and marta i think exemplifies that and
you know great people bring in
other great people so uh three four
years ago ginny lee
joined as the president and ceo of khan
academy we'll get ginny on
on this i think she's being shy uh we'll
get ginny on
on on the live stream soon but jenny you
know just as marta could be a leader at
pretty much any organization in silicon
valley or beyond ginny as well could
and then ginny has helped kind of
provide
that consistency that process uh
bringing people along if you have 200
folks you can't just
you know my instinct is kind of like oh
let's get this done by this afternoon
that done but if 200 folks they'll just
get
you know we'll be moving in different
directions um so jenny's provided that
leadership and one of the best things
about leadership
is to bring other really amazing people
in so marta was one of the first people
that ginny brought in and ginny knows
how to hire and then marta knows how to
hire and develop and build teams
we already had a really good team when
it was small and marta's been able to
get them to the next level but then also
put in
the the processes and and the
institutional knowledge so that people
can really make a career
out of being at khan academy so you know
to answer the question what marta brings
you know these projects if marta wasn't
here and if she wasn't able to lead the
team that she's leading in the way that
she's
doing it i don't think it's an
exaggeration to say when covet hit
you a lot of y'all might not have been
able to access khan academy
i mean that's just in plain uh you know
and there would have been millions of
people
who would have not been able to learn uh
so uh
because our site probably wouldn't have
been able to scale or or
even if it was working it would probably
take in 20 seconds for you to
access certain pages which would have
been very frustrating for for millions
of millions of people
uh so i think that's one level and the
other thing which marta does is
you know i have so much confidence in
marta and her team
that it allows me to uh focus
more energy on where i think i might
have
have value uh you know of you know
what's the future of khan academy going
to be where we're going to be in five
years you know i've
spent a lot of time fundraising i still
make a lot of content and it's not that
i'm detached i'm
i'm deeply interested and i want to
support martin and the team wherever i
can
but when you have really amazing leaders
leaders that you can learn from you know
i learn from marta i learn from ginny
and and many others every day about
their craft about how to lead people
about how to lead an org uh that just
takes a lot
off of off of my plate so yeah i
consider myself very very fortunate
uh to have to have mard on this team
well that's
very very nice of you to say uh and
we're very
fortunate to be here
oh thank you so this is from oh time
always runs out fast when we're having
fun but i think we have time for maybe a
few more
and this is a good question um and maybe
we could both take a shot at this one
from youtube nikuraj
asks how do you face criticism
after having failed at something
have you ever failed at anything i fail
at something every day
so so how do you deal with it like tell
me something that you failed that you
kind of hit you and maybe even you got
criticism
how did you how did you cope yeah that's
a great question i'll think of one and
you think of one at the same time see if
we
don't have much time left what would be
a good one to talk about i certainly
have an abundance of choices
of mistakes that i make i mean i'm
serious when i say that i make mistakes
um all the time and i learn from my team
all the time literally every day
and and gain insights from what folks
that are doing
um and uh let me think of a spectacular
failure if i can because that's probably
a better story
[Music]
we can compete for largest failures yeah
do you have one you have ready to share
i'm still oh well
i have many i mean from uh from uh
economic point of view people don't know
so i was working at a hedge fund and
then my boss wanted to retire and he
wanted me to essentially start my own
hedge fund
this was pre-khan academy and i
essentially took over his cost structure
and
i lost a person and this is you know i
didn't own a house
the only money me and my family had was
essentially a down payment we were
saving up for a house and
uh i lost uh almost 200 000
and so you can imagine our down payment
for our house quickly became not
sufficient to buy a house and so i took
long lot walks
in in the hills out here in silicon
valley trying to
you know not trying to trying to save my
ego
and uh you know i would look at
squirrels and i said you know that
squirrel doesn't know i just lost 200
000
maybe we can be friends and that kind of
gave me
because it affects you in very deep ways
i think we're oftentimes our biggest
critics and we start saying
you know what will my family think of me
what will my um
friends think of me i've been such a
massive failure will i ever be able to
recover from this
will people ever want to work with me
when they've seen this failure will they
hire me you know i mean there's really
big questions
uh and you know in terms of how do you
cope with it you realize when you go
through these things over and over again
in your life
uh that you they they pass
and things do get better as long as you
put one foot in front of the other and
so now that i've had
you know i've had probably four or five
of these big failures in my life and
i've had
probably four or five hundred of lesser
failures in my life
that in that days also seemed fairly
catastrophic
um i realized that as long as i put one
foot in front of the other have a
positive attitude keep meditating
a month later i don't even remember what
that was or a year later i can kind of
talk about it on a live stream like i'm
a you know a wise soul
you have to get back to our meditation
kind of you know
buddhist philosophy roots i mean a big
part of it is just
you know the stories we tell ourselves
and so you know not berating yourself
it's true i mean the most important
thing is is we are ourselves we're all
born as pretty perfect little beings and
we do get screwed up along the way
with various things but we are you know
that's
that's still there right we all have you
know the bad and the good
and we all can get better every day and
so not calling yourself a screw up or
thinking that you screwed up so badly
that no one should love you
is a really important i'm a really
important way to lead your life
i think no that's exactly right i mean
you know bringing up the
buddhist or eastern or vedic philosophy
there's all this notion of
non-non-attachment
that it's only when we get attached to
our personas or these
narratives around our personas or
attached to materiality
that that's actually the cause of
suffering true suffering you know
there's pain which is you're getting you
know there's a needle in your arm
there's suffering which is the mental
state where it you know it kind of
catastrophize things and and it causes
anxiety
and but when you realize that you know
there's there's a part of you that's
purer than that that is not your persona
that is not your identity that is not
your role that is not your name
that it's actually very peace inducing
and liberating and actually helps you
get out of your
your rut many times so not to preach too
much
uh but marta thanks so much i mean
there's so many more questions i think
we will do this again
if you did if this wasn't uh a horrible
event for you
and so but but thank you so much for for
joining we will do this again and thanks
everyone for
uh asking questions uh so uh once again
you know this is always fun we have
these great conversations i encourage
everyone
uh to join us tomorrow for ongoing
conversations and we're going to be
talking about
kind of child development and and how we
raise our children and generational
changes so thanks everyone for joining
today's live stream
you